[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing none other than draco malfoy
bully slytherin and heartthrob draco
malfoy was a british pure blood wizard
born in the year 1980 the son of
narcissa malfoy and death eater lucius
malfoy draco started at hogwarts in the
same year as harry ron and hermione and
many of the other characters that we're
all so familiar with right off the bat
we sort of get a sense of the type of
character that draco malfoy is going to
be a certain type of person that i'd
imagine all of us have witnessed at some
point or another jk rowling discusses
this further
everybody recognizes draco because
everybody has known somebody like him
such people's belief in their own
superiority can be infuriating laughable
or intimidating depending on the
circumstances in which one meets them
draco succeeds in provoking all of these
feelings in harry ron and hermione at
one point in time or another after the
sorting ceremony draco is placed into
slytherin house and harry is placed into
gryffindor house
this is basically the beginning of the
proper rivalry between draco and harry
potter throughout the books and films
draco is a constant nuisance towards the
trio and as he grows older his behavior
turns from annoying but still childlike
and playful to rather sinister however
one thing i'd like to mention is that
unsurprisingly the films left out
certain actions and aspects of draco's
character but you can't blame the
filmmakers for this books are rich with
information and the film is trying to
condense all of that information into a
reasonable time frame i mean i'd watch
an eight hour harry potter film but i'm
not sure it would have been too inviting
to newcomers with all of that said the
film still gave us a lot of draco's
character but certainly not everything
and in today's video i want to discuss
10 things that only book readers will
know about harry's nemesis
without further ado let's get started
10. he helps rita skeeter slander harry
as far as journalists go rita skeeter is
about as conniving as it comes born in
1951 she was a british witch and
journalist that would write defamation
pieces full of misinformation for the
daily prophet her reputation was awful
and no one was safe from her poison
pieces even albus dumbledore who once
remarked that skeeter was enchantingly
nasty so as you can imagine the boy who
lived was the ultimate target for
skeeter and safe from her he was not in
the goblet of fire skeeter makes harry's
life rather difficult but this isn't
actually that clear in the films her
role is less substantial furthermore in
the books it's revealed that draco
actually acts as rita's informant giving
rita information on harry in order to
discredit him draco was very much aware
of the immense pressure harry was under
re the tribe was a tournament and he
wanted to make his life even more
difficult
9. he gets harry banned from quidditch
draco wasn't the best quidditch player
at least not in the beginning sure he
made it onto the slytherin team but
that's likely largely due to his
father's generous contributions however
being harry's rival he had to get on the
team and he had to represent his house
while he beat harry at quidditch however
draco didn't end up getting a one-up on
harry very often in the order of the
phoenix draco mocks harry after
gryffindor beats slytherin bringing up
the death of his parents once more fred
and george respond rather aggressively
and for this they are given quidditch
bans however when umbridge hears of what
happens she decides to ban harry as well
despite the fact that draco had provoked
them eight he threatens borgin with
fenrir greyback as we know the death
eaters are in alliance with the
werewolves particularly one werewolf
fenrir greyback we also know that the
malfoys who are death eaters are
reasonably close with greyback at least
close enough to drop his name in order
to incite fear in another witch or
wizard whether it was all talk or not is
up to you to decide but that doesn't
refute the fact that one stage draco
threatens a borgian from borgen and
berks with the terrifying werewolf you
know fenrir greyback he's a family
friend he'll be dropping in from time to
time to make sure you're giving the
problem your full attention the reason
draco threatens him relates to his use
of the vanishing cabinets with one being
located in borgin's shop 7. he actually
meets harry before hogwarts remember the
handshake scene from the film the one at
hogwarts where draco slanders ron and
then puts out his hand to harry in the
films this is the first time harry meets
draco you'll soon find out some
wizarding families are much better than
others potter you don't want to go
making friends with the wrong sort i can
help you there this scene still happens
in the books just on the hogwarts
express instead of hogwarts itself
however with that said this is not the
first time that they meet in the book
the first time that they meet is at
madame malkin's robes for all occasions
in diagon alley 6. he never left
hogwarts during the final showdown with
voldemort this is bit of a big one that
was changed and i'm not exactly sure why
it was changed as it really didn't need
it in the deathly hallows part 2 before
voldemort met his demise the malfoy's
narcissa lucius and draco end up leaving
the hogwarts grounds curiously they
leave on foot making a dramatic exit
most likely in order to make a statement
that they were no longer on voldemort's
side
however in the books this is quite
different as instead of leaving the
hogwarts grounds they remain there
awkwardly waiting around in the great
hall after voldemort is killed
five he gets beaten up by harry ron and
hermione being a constant bully a
nuisance to the trio of the course of
the books films certainly didn't come
without its consequences particularly on
one occasion where all parties are
aboard the hogwarts express on the train
back from hogwarts draco attempts to
bully a particularly sensitive harry who
had just witnessed cedric's death but
this time harry had had enough and he
ends up jumping draco along with ron
hermione fred and george
4. he gets beaten up again but just by
ron
now in the books draco gets hit a couple
of times with one very noteworthy
occasion being the time that hermione
slapped him across the face
look at him blubber have you ever seen
anything quite as pathetic said malfoy
and he's supposed to be our teacher
harry and ron both made furious moves
towards malfoy but hermione got there
first smack she had slapped malfoy
across the face with all the strength
she could muster but as it turns out
hermione wasn't the only one to hit
draco in fact in the deathly hallows ron
weasley himself ends up punching draco
after saving his life inside the room of
requirement and that's the second time
we've saved your life tonight you
two-faced bastard three he makes crab
and goyal take paulie juice potion polly
juice potion is an unusual one a potion
that enables the consumer to assume the
physical appearance of another person in
essence body juice lets you impersonate
people really really well
the potion is notably used by barty
crouch jr in order to impersonate moody
but it's actually used a few more times
in the story the other fairly notable
time that it's used is when draco
convinces his henchman or lackeys to
take the potion hoping to use the room
of requirement undetected he gets crab
and goyle to drink the potion and keep
an eye on it
two he taunts the trio during a death
eater attack if you remember the goblet
of fire then you'll remember that chaos
erupts at the quidditch world cup when
death eaters attack
this was a major attack on the good guys
and the reappearance of the dark mark a
harsh reminder that voldemort's regime
was still very much alive in the books
during the death eater attack the trio
wander into the woods where they find a
draco in typical draco fashion it's here
that he taunts them particularly
hermione granger they're after muggles
do you want to be showing off your
knickers in mid-air because if you do
hang around they're moving this way and
it would give us all a laugh number one
he has a tantrum when buckbeak escapes
at one stage in the harry potter books
and films we're introduced to buckbeak a
hippogriff that hagrid introduces to
students in his care for magical
creatures class however buckbeak didn't
exactly have the same relationship with
all the students harry for example was
able to ride buckbeak but draco didn't
have the same experience draco ends up
taunting buckbeak to which he receives
an injury completely furious draco ends
up trying to get buckbeak killed with
the hippogriff eventually being
sentenced to death by the ministry of
magic fortunately buckbeak is eventually
saved by harry hermione and the time
turner what the film doesn't include
here however is just how angry draco and
his father were after buck peak's escape
and that's it for this video did you
know all of these did i miss some if you
enjoyed the content please like the
video subscribe to the channel and leave
a comment down below until next time my
father will hear about this
you